a few days ago paramount and Sega
announced their joint collaboration on
Sonic II hatch up to considering the
immense popularity in the sequence at
the end of the first part this doesn't
come as a surprise to many true to the
motto never change a winning team not
only director Jeff Fowler but also his
authors Patrick Casey Joshua Miller and
the successful producers Neal H Moritz
and Tim Miller will work together again
on a sequel Sonic the Hedgehog turned
out to be a real surprise set after a
disastrous outrage due to the appearance
of the star character after the
community strongly demanded that the
human-like proportions of the videogame
characters should be changed the studio
actually gave in in the end and
therefore built a foundation for the
worldwide revenue of 307 million u.s.
dollars the fact that many countries
have already shut down their cinemas
before the release of Sonic is quite
remarkable since what film generates
over 300 million in box office revenue
with a large part of the important Asian
film market whether the story around the
world's fastest Hedgehog will be
seamlessly continued in the second part
or whether we can expect a prequel is
unfortunately not certain at the moment
after the shooting of the Batman has
been paused for many weeks now they are
finally some news about the long-awaited
DC spectacle on the one hand there are
freshly released concept pictures of the
new Batmobile which have not received
much enthusiasm so far fortunately the
Twitter account the bat Robert still has
two now largely removed pictures in its
feet which is why you can still view the
questionable designs of traffic designer
Jeff Frost many fans claim that the
model reminds more of the high-tech
vehicle a kit from the movie Knight
Rider than the Batmobile from the past
movies and the fans are not wrong
because the model really looks like a
muscle car from the 80s but there are
also fans who actually like the are
typical aesthetics of the new vehicle
which are not so unusual for Batman some
twitter users are happy that the
Batmobile now looks like a real car and
not like a failed tank and even if Jeff
Ross concept is currently questioned
there's another piece of news they will
probably please everyone the British
government is given the permission for a
lot of shootings in the near future so
the production will be restarted on a
strict condition soon of course this
also applies to other movies so Batman
is not the exception
besides the Batman Mission Impossible
seven and eight are also affected by the
suspended shoot
Great Britain what other movies try to
start as soon as possible the production
of both movies will even be passed until
September
especially the shooting plant theory
that carnival on Venice has set the
production extremely back as assistant
director Tom ego milena reports it is
hoped that the completion of the plan
seems will be finalized between
September and May if no second wave of
virus destroys the plans of a Mission
Impossible team the carnival scene
priced by insiders can be expected the
Batman is expected to be released on
October 1st 2021 while Mission
Impossible 7 and 8 are planned for
November 19 20 21 and November 4th 2021
many Marvel fans were disappointed by
the removal of daredevil Jessica Jones
and Luke Cage from Netflix since
November 2018 fans have been waiting for
return of Drew Goddard series after the
first season in particular was very well
received by fans and critics the fan
campaign safe daredevil has now
published by a screen rant that only six
month remain until the rights of the
series are no longer held by Netflix but
by Marvel again the reason for this is a
contract between Marvel and Netflix
which says the characters daredevil Luke
Cage and Jessica Jones can only be used
by Marvel again after two years now the
question arises of course how Marvel
will reuse its regained rights one
possibility would be to simply publish
this series started by Netflix on an
in-house streaming service like Disney
Plus or Hulu it would also be
conceivable to reboot the whole series
with new actors for the time being there
is probably nothing else to do but wait
and hope for official announcements
[Music]